just saw anybody identifies their table
is you know am i talking about entrants
and high dimensions so prepare to be
entertained thank you it's a pleasure to
be here and give this talk points to
John for not seeing Jelena so the title
of the talk is slightly different but
actually it's the same kind of message
that I want to share so my particular
view of robustness is removing this
strenuous assumptions of everything
being sparse or being sparse at the
order of and to two thirds or and to one
half or maybe just an so why can't we
actually do in this regard okay I don't
have a lot of pictures so you know
thanking my collaborators is always a
good thing to start majority of the work
was done by my former PhD student in
Chizu and he's been great to work with
ok so a brief outline of the talk I want
to first motivate why is this maybe an
interesting problem to look at or maybe
a difficult problem to look at and then
I'm gonna propose four different
specifications or different settings of
interest what would be the solution and
regarding theoretical properties I
largely probably skip some parts but I
want to focus on what we call now a new
detection boundary so we actually now
have for the first time minimax results
that do not depend on sparsity and do
allow in fact dimensions of the problem
to be exponentially larger than the
number of samples and then of course I
should convince you that these things
that I'm talking about actually work
okay so here's the setting this is a
setting throughout the paper so what is
the question that I want to look at
largely I want to look at this equation
- you can zoom in mint there's a lot of
text on here but I want to actually be
able to say whether or not the small
hypothesis is kind of true so can I
actually test this problem
the setting is linear regression and I
particularly have written it in a
convenient way where this parameter is
univariate didn't want to test and
everything else is nuisance and in the
model and in particular my nuisance is
linear and where the this talk is
largely connected or it's connected a
lot I guess we will see how much with
Lester stock on orthogonal moments and
so on so where Lester's trying to
showcase general setting for defining
new moment conditions I would actually
do the opposite I would zoom in into a
particular problem and showcase that
there is solutions that's large you can
remove a lot of assumptions for this
particular problem of interest so in
general right under this setting I want
to be able to say can I actually answer
quantifiably this hypothesis testing
problem and under what conditions on the
sparsity can I do that what kind of
sparsity so typically I would call the
sparsity of gamma as model sparsity and
a lot of inference procedures in the
literature assume that the order of the
SAS sub gamma scales at this rate there
is some work by Adele and Anthea
and others where you can maybe remove
some part of this Carew then and Lester
has shown this n can be and not one-half
but two over three and all of that but
what I would actually like to do is
allow this estimate P okay so I would
not like to have assumed that things are
sparse largely because you know you meet
this you have this real
in front of you and do you actually know
the things are sparse I mean it's
believed that we are putting on it's a
hat that we're putting on in order to be
able to say something in high dimensions
but honestly we don't really know right
can can we test for it again we don't
know how there is no task procedure they
can test whether this particular data
satisfies parsecity assumption so when
that happens or with this motivation in
mind I was thinking okay maybe this is
just a mathematical problem maybe just
the existing methods really do work but
I have to maybe look into a MP's to
prove more prove more things but what I
want to show you is that that's not the
case so I'll skip over this let me show
you a plot so what you're seeing here is
type 1 error what you want to see is
type 1 error below 5% or designated
alpha so different colors here
correspond to different alpha levels 10%
1% so let's focus on 5 which is yellow I
hope you can see that it looks better on
the computer okay so what the x-axis
explains the value of the gamma if you
remember the nuisance parameter my true
parameter of course is zero but all of
the gammas and my P is 500 so I have 500
nuisance elements in my model each of
the nuisance is really small okay or
maybe not small so this is what also is
telling me right and the set this is
similar meaning the result is
theoretical but the plot is just showing
the limiting result of the type 1 error
and what you see is that when alpha is
close to 0 you you kind of have a 5%
control on the type 1 error when the
minute alpha moves away so even this 2
if you read off your type 1 error is 30%
and if you look at here you have a test
that's worse than coin flip this is
univariate problem in high dimensions
where I didn't say which method is
giving me this it's the semi
parametrically optimal D biased which
I fit with the true correlation matrix
I'm not estimating anything I'm just you
know this is a super optimal method
according to the current results so
indeed it seems that the method is not
able to overcome this limitation it's
not purely theoretical right so what can
we say what can we do so there here's a
little literature review have a little
colorful table so what happens with this
high dimensional inference procedures
you have to sort of elements that play a
role
one is the sparsity of the model so when
you see non sparse model I mean all
elements are full I don't mean sparsity
of certain rate I mean sparse it is P
when I see when you see moderate model
which is here I actually mean sparsity
can grow at the order of n which is
already more than square root of n but
that's what people would call moderate
sparsity another thing that plays a
large role is the sparsity of your
precision matrix the Omega or the Sigma
inverse typically called feature partial
correlation between your features all of
that right so if you have some sparsity
structure there I would call that
moderate sparse designs or moderate
design again moderate means the sparsity
grows at certain rate and non sparse
design means think about gaussian
multivariate gaussian with correlation
point 9 you know so fully full matrix so
pretty crazy things right
so I think the other things are easier
to explain so fix design is we all know
non-random design asymptotics means that
the results are actually asymptotic in
nature so I have to take a limit at some
point where n tends to infinity or not
and unknown design means that I don't
need to know that the distribution of X
in order to do things right so on the
row space here you see so maybe our dear
score so we BR d stands for Peters work
with bunch of coca-cola collaborators
score is the score method of Hanley UN
cockers it's I can't tell what the
difference is between the two other than
one is first and one is second in the
literature but anyways so when you see
the sign yes that means that the method
is working it's giving a tight control
of type one error when the design is
unknown but it also gives results for
fixed design I think that only applies
to VB Rd so van de Geer woman Desiree
and I forget the are anyhow so it
doesn't the results are asymptotic in
nature but when you read the paper you
see that the sparsity that's required on
both the model and the precision matrix
is of the order of square root n okay so
no no means you can't really use it and
everything okay then there is a Dells
work with them yeah so what they were
able to actually work out is theory of
okay so what if I don't have to estimate
my precision matrix exactly everywhere
just diagonally can I improve things and
you can and what they I think I'm
quoting you right just maybe maybe at my
table is outdated but yeah you can tell
me later but the result says that you
can actually do things for moderate
design and even maybe non-sports design
I've I think your paper still applies
but still the model has to be as first
stars means clear and sparse and then
there is this Model X knockoff Center
the manuals work so the interesting
thing there is that if you know the
design you can do a lot of things so you
don't need the sparsity in the model
alone it's parse it in the precision
there is sequence of paper some are high
dimensional some are low dimensional but
largely either you have to simulate out
this unknown design and it's unclear how
to extend it purely in that area but
what is very interesting I want to
strike out here is that I'll come back
to that later is that if you actually do
know the distribution of X
you don't even have to estimate anything
you can have an optimal test just so
which is kind of counterintuitive
because my testing is relating to
conditional distribution of Y given X
and I'm not making assumption on that
I'm only making assumption on X and I
think Model X kind of means that right
here just assuming things on X then
there is Toni ties group at UPenn has
done a lot of work on extending things
to moderate designs that's about it as
far as I know and it's all oh yeah so an
Model X knockoff is non asymptotic in
nature where is all of this remaining
results are nice Atari so um okay of
course there is double machine learning
but I guess we've seen that now this can
be improved but the idea there is that
you really actually need you cannot
allow sparse models you can maybe allow
I think the proof actually extends to
moderate design but the paper itself
does not talk about it but I think it
does and then the method that we talked
that I'll talk about is called
correlation testing or core teach it
tries to fill out this gap where you can
have these yeses but to be clear I
cannot have both yeses at the same time
so either my model is fully danced or my
future correlation matrix is fully
danced not both at the same time okay so
that's literature review so it turns out
big picture kind of message before I go
into the details is that if you do use
this orthogonal score alone it's not
enough to actually remove this varsity
assumption I think that's kind of the
same message as lessor saying you have
to change something but the thing that
we will change are the estimators
themselves not the not the score but how
you construct your estimators in fact we
came a roundabout way at this moment
condition that I'll show case and I
think our intuition is coming from IV
rather than orthogonality largely
because econometrics is I'm just
learning it as of now can't say I know
it okay
but what you see is that okay if I
actually work pretend I put my h0 hat on
and I'm under the null hypothesis
setting I can actually write my linear
model in the following way so I know the
value of beta zero may be zero maybe nah
doesn't matter but my null is something
and I represent my model in this way I
can see that under H no this model is
nice nice means that the error is unlist
uncorrelated with the design under h1 on
on the other hand this is not not not
true anymore so the error in the model
has correlation with the design and in
specifically we know how we can see that
the correlation is driven through this Z
so you look into the literature of Ivy
and you see okay this is a well-known
problem there what you do you invent
this instrument but I don't have to
invent an instrument I actually know
what my instrument should be should be
this is e so if I regress my Z on to
this X in a new model and I think we
find a lot of things I'm saying things
there may be Gaussian things are linear
I'll be honest at the end and say at
which points what is important though
Shanna T is not important that that's
maybe one thing I can clearly say and I
want to say linearity in this model is
not important linearity in this model as
long as my Z is a real value this okay
doesn't matter but if it's binary
they're they're issues so if you do that
then you notice what that you can
transform your initial hypothesis of
interest into this moment condition so
my H null is true my previous H now if
and only if the the you can think of
this as moment condition is actually
holding true and when you stare at it
enough this is exactly Leicester's or
double machine learning moment condition
for a specific case of linear models
but we truly came about it from IV
perspective and it's kind of interesting
that they match but this is helpful
right so the idea is now can I actually
build a test that's related to equation
four I'm not going to solve the
equations like what is typically done in
double machine learning but I will use
the this to create a test before I do
that I would like to say how is it that
we are changing our estimators if you
don't change estimators in you plug in
lots of dancing or your favourite thing
nothing really works well and what we've
done we introduced this constrained
dancing you could play it with different
names but I'm not very talented that way
inventing very fancy ways names
so I'll just constraint dancing because
the first part of your estimation
problem here looks exactly like dancing
you're encouraging sparsity right
although remember my model is not sparse
so all I need is I know a priori that
this estimator cannot be a good
estimator but as long as it's not
terrible I'm hoping I can do well so
what does it mean to be terrible or
controllably bad for me it means that
the size of the estimated residuals
which are measured in this constraint
with infinity norm is think about
bounded with a constant there is some
rate here because we want to be able to
say that you don't have to tune all of
these parameters but that's what we need
and what happens with this inference
problems is that well not only do you
need the estimation of your parameter of
interest you need the estimator of the
variance at the same time and in high
dimensions that's a little tricky so
we've just embedded this last constraint
in order to be able to estimate the
variance components so the variance here
is denoted with Sigma and I'm going to
treat and this is indeed like a
parametric Li LP okay so you can use
simplex method to run it for all values
of Sigma so it does not cost you any
time at all
okay so another way to look at this is
that this gamma is you can plot it as
function of Sigma and I'm gonna choose
the Sigma such that this equation seven
is actually true equation seven if you
see I cannot guarantee that there is a
solution if I have some consistency here
okay so what what do I mean by that so
if the truth is really sparse I'm hoping
that this estimator is a good one in
other words it should be close to last
certainty if the model is not sparse I
the only thing I actually kind of need
is that my estimator of variance is not
hitting zero because obviously things
will explode and my estimated residuals
are not going to be large and why I
estimated residuals let me go back a
minute to two point this moment
condition in equation 4 and you'll see
that here is here's that estimated
residual right if that is small while
this other part is converging to zero
not small but bounded or growing but at
a slower rate I should be fine so it
turns out that this constraint dancing
it really works well it doesn't like I
said you don't need then the knowledge
of the noise level and you do not really
need to tune anything so these
quantities come out of concentration
inequalities and all of that but they
seem to be robust ok so you can do the
same thing for theta it will look the
same because everything is linear but
you are technically separating them and
I'm not doing simple splitting just
because in the proof so I can get away
with it I think the only reason why
other things need sample studying is
that you need independence of this
estimated residuals and then you you
utilize that in proof techniques but
here it's ok it's doable so your test
statistic looks like the question 8
which is a sample version of the moment
conditions and I want to maybe pause a
little bit and maybe convinced you why
would this thing work right it seems
like it shouldn't right but what happens
is that I am estimating
one of these two things at the rate
that's faster than a twitch the other
one is diverging and when you look at
that so suppose that actually gamma is
not sparse so this estimated residuals
are not going to be small however you
know this u which is a residual coming
out of the second component of the
moment will actually drive the
asymptotics as long as they have some
self normalizing some that's going to
control the growth of the weights so you
can think of these guys as weighted
linear combinations of U or the weights
are random but they're not too big and
remember these are univariate quantities
so things work out so as long as I can
estimate theta at a good rate I'm good I
can allow gamma to be non sparse
completely so how is this idea so in
linear case it seems everything is nice
and for univariate parameters I mean we
have some extension for multivariate
parameters so if you have multiple
testing but I won't talk today about
that but I want to mention this linear
tests that appear in different settings
so what if I I am NOT no longer
interested in testing only one parameter
beta but I'm interested in testing this
linear combinations of beta and I want
to say these are called linear contrast
in statistics just because of what I
want to highlight is that this a is not
allowed to be random this a fixed number
that's given to you okay so this does
not apply to for example treatment
effects and other things where a would
be X you know some part of X matrix
that's not a lot okay so what can I do
for this kind of quantities and it turns
out here you also have to worry about
whether this linear combination is a
sparse linear combination or a dense
linear combination so whether a is
sparse whether beta sparse and all of
that so let me show you on this example
how would this test look like if I
actually just know the distribution of
okay I'm not gonna estimate anything
which means I can allow P to be crazy
high I can allow us to be crazy high and
all of that but it's a simplified
assumption but I think it's highlighting
this principle that I would like
personally to understand better how is
that knowing X is so so helpful okay so
suppose I know Sigma of X think about X
multivariate Gaussian but it could be
subbed out on with variance covariance
matrix Sigma X so what I'll do is I'll
utilize this decomposition here of the
feature space basically I'm going to
project into the linear space spanned by
a and Omega Omega is the inverse of
Sigma and I'll utilize that in with this
idea can I just keep part of the feature
space that's actually informative for my
now because my null is a transpose beta
and can I lift everything else that's
kind of the idea where the useful part
is this vector Z and the not useful part
is this W okay so that's all I'm gonna
do remember I know AI know oh my god I
have my X's so I can always do this I
can just be projections what happens is
that your model of interest now looks
like that so I've inserted this null
hypothesis into my model structure and I
want to do the same kind of trick that I
was doing before that's kind of beauty
and it looks simple it looks algebraic
and your test in this case doesn't quite
look like orthogonal moments because
again you don't really need to do
anything here what you notice is that
under the now this thing is true so the
product so this is new equation let me
go back again I'm sorry
so this is the equip the red equation is
what I'm working with so under the now
this thing in the parentheses is G
naught right so then i know that y i-
jean zi g naught which is written here
should not have correlation with zi
because I have created the eyes using
the null
it's not it's orthogonal to the now okay
so that's that
there's no beta Z depends on the null
I'm not estimating anything and then
your test looks like that right so it
seems really simple and naive and I was
surprised to see nothing nothing has
been done like this but that's all you
need to do if I know the distribution of
X which means this test we mean it's
easy to show right this is a synthetic
ly normal at the right rate in semper
mightily efficient and all of that but
the beauty is this is you know Gaussian
thing no matter what no matter what your
P is no matter what your s is no matter
what your signal-to-noise ratio is it's
kind of unbelievable to me personally
it's a small thing so what do we do if
if I don't know the distribution of X
well I would like to do something this
similar but again I can't really do
something similar so first I'll pretend
that my features are uncorrelated and
I'm gonna do the same projection as
before and then I'm going to D no is it
a little bit because I know that
actually my Sigma of X is not identity
and when I do know is it which means
just this you know write decompose the
identity in this way with you a being
the orthogonal matrix then I know I can
write my original problem now in this
way so disease the same as before in
fact and the wi tilts have additional
component in it what happens here is
that now this WI till they're not quite
thirst agonal to z they're they're
trying to be but they're not quite there
yet so okay I have some new nuisance
parameter but who cares I also didn't
obey that start right something else I
can do it okay so then what happens is
that you you get to see that if you form
residuals and you regress your Z's on
this W is basically two orthogonalize
everything and then you you you see that
your null hypothesis can be re-written
in this way
and then now everything looks very
similar to previous setting it's just
Newsies and UW's but everything is kind
of the same and indeed the whole test
looks kind of the same so I think this
is really simple maybe you're not
convinced that this actually works so
here the conditions that we need for the
procedure to have control of type 1
error remember I am trying to have a
test that has alpha level 4 under no
sparsity that's my primary goal i have
sub gaussian designs i have this moment
condition on the epsilon that they don't
have to be gaussian the dimension of the
problem can grow this rate this delta is
this delta so if i have higher up
moments that allows me or I have some
constraint in that says
that's the assumption on the design
largely the assumption of the model and
on the sparsity looks like that so
sparks and I'm only taking a view where
the model is non sparse and and this
theta which is in the linear case
actually the vector the column in your
Omega matrix scales the disorder okay so
there's some sparsity in the Omega
matrix there's no sparsity in the comma
but I'm assuming that gamma lies in this
l2 ball of bounded size I'll come back
to that later when I talk about mini Mac
city so if one is to remove this I'm
going to show theoretically that you
cannot achieve any alpha level 100 I
said oh you can but everything skills
with this l2 norm
so it's undo you know not over okay so
those are the only assumptions so under
those two assumptions are the tests that
I've shown you for the linear model so
I'm forgetting about the linear contrast
testing for the moment because it's
simpler to talk about linear models you
I have an alpha level test okay so what
I didn't highlight is that again I can
be ambivalent as to whether gamma is far
sir whether theta is worse
so whether my model is sparse or I have
too much correlations and you'll still
get the same result
so again sparsity in gamma is allowed to
be P so here's this robustness property
so when we did this the usual thing that
we were asked was well yes you have this
thing that doesn't work with when you
have no sparsity does it lose anything
when you actually have sparsity and the
answer is no so if everything is sparse
the estimators are adapting to it in
fact and offline I can talk about
adaptivity that we've formally proved
only recently but the my answer no is
substantiated by the following fact I
want to look at type 2 error of my test
and if everything is sparse if I have
the same power function as all of the
semi-parametric the optimal things then
I'll be able to say yes I'm not losing
anything right and that's exactly what
happens so if everything is sparse this
part technically we can still allow
moderate sparsity and still get you know
optimal power function we get the same
power curve as as JM Adele and and yeah
as Peters work and and all this others
so that's nice right so if everything is
pursed I'm not losing anything for a
longest time we couldn't really prove
power properties in general settings
because what do we mean in general
setting things are not dense so what is
my optimal alternative is my alternative
allowed to be sparser is my alternative
not allowed to be sparse or how does
that work so at the beginning this is
kind of historical view how we came
about it we we looked at let me show you
this more general result which is we
looked at specific cases and we were
able to show that for specific cases we
can do things optimally what is the
specific case the specific case is that
the gamma was this mixture of dense and
sparse vectors so what I mean by that
you can imagine that oftentimes you know
you have these genetic data sets where
you have a bunch of things that is
driving the signal and then Oh
the others are really small but you
still have them they're nonzero so you
imagine a vector like this where you
know a bunch of things are kind of
actively doing things and that all of
the rest are really small okay
so in my notation this is PI and this is
mu right so if I believe that that's
that decomposition kind of works then
what we showed was that you can you get
still the optimal power optimal as if
things were sparse and everything was
nice so the statement on the slides just
basically tells us that and then more
recently we were able to talk about this
minimax detection boundaries so we were
wondering okay so can we have a general
class of problems for which we can
actually show this optimality kind of
holds and what I'm showing you on this
slide is a corollary which is a minimax
type of statement but before I talk
about it I want to say that the way we
actually achieve this result is through
an invention of a new concept which we
called uniform non testability so
minimax results typically say okay find
me the worst but only one possible
direction in the alternative and compute
my power in that direction and that's
going to be your lower bound basically
right what happens here is that when you
have dense problems it's very easy to
find a million such points and they
wouldn't be very informative because you
know you can find a sparse one and not
sparse one because the sparse one has
scales with s and my FF my SP I know
that's not optimal I know I can do
better so what we said okay so what if I
constrain myself to look at the region
in the alternative space that's bad
right it's not just one direction but I
have a concentrated region of points can
i actual
say something about that and that has
led to this result that doesn't allow or
allows sparsity to make P and still have
minimax type statements so the s that
you see here is the s of theta
what you see here is that I am able to
formulate there's a lot of notations
that I don't want to kill you over at
night time you know Tuesday but let me
highlight the things you know it's
saying that your test is doing well
alpha is the alpha level Phi is your
particular test you have supremum over
all alpha level test in this parameter
space in equation 12 and then you have
your alternative space structure design
here in this infimum what you see here
is the rate in the bottom that drives
the alternative space so which means
that if my alternative is this far away
so square root n plus this extra term
away from the now I'm able to detect it
okay so s is the sparsity of again of
Sigma inverse not of the model so what
you see here is that unless you have
sparsity first of all unless you have
sparsity in the precision matrix
you cannot detect anything actually we
have a very negative result the
reviewers are not they don't like
negative ourselves but statistics but
what it says is that even if your
alternative is a constant distance away
you know you're not able to detect
anything you know no sparsity in the
model no sparsity in the in the
procedure matrix which i think is very
powerful and illuminating to kind of
know you need some structure to work
around but right this tells us what is
the optimal rate detection right and and
you see there is no sparsity on gamma so
gamma can be p and this is still true
let me go back to that assumption that
the l2 norm of gamma was considered to
be constant what we now know is that
this actually you can just attach the l2
norm of gamma on it if it's exploding
within you
not you cannot get anything but again we
have all these negative results but the
positive result you know or a positive I
mean what I'm highlighting what how does
this detection boundary look like what
we call the essential uniform non
testability
so this is to look into the alternative
space and find the ball essentially a
ball of drawn points or bad points okay
there's lots of constants that are
playing the oldest rules but essentially
it really already says what I've
mentioned so I'll just go so let me try
to finish off with some numerical
experiments I think they're really
illuminating and real data but I can
talk offline of you know offline about
this minimax results and how interesting
you know mound gets you know without
sparsity so here is super simple
studying of simulations ltd stands for
light tail design everything is Gaussian
so the design is gaussian correlation is
top 'lets decaying depending on i'll
change row zero will take different
values so you'll see what happens
htd is heavy tail design so what we did
here we basically took or generated
multi variate student T distribution
with three degrees of freedom
so pretty heavy tail we also have light
tailed error which is Gaussian and heavy
tail there which we just picked student
T somehow what is not clear in our
results I'll be fast is that this
methodology is also robust to the error
distribution which is not what we aimed
for but this is the traditional sense of
robustness in statistics which is
unusual because you would think you need
a different kind of thing going on but
let me show you
tables are nasty I don't have a
time to let me show you a plot so this
first plot is everything is sparse the
second plot is my sparsity is n over 2
now it's n actually
so my sparse it is N and is 100-piece
500 and this last one is Parsa t is 500
so sparse it is beam our method is red
we have green line is the biasing method
and score so for the d bias method we
are plugging in the true value of the
Omega okay so in that sense the the
condition we are looking at is
equivalent to JMS so so what you see is
H is the value in the alternative you
have type 1 error here and then you have
power right what you see for example in
sparsity is 500 is that all of these
existing methods have type 1 error 50
percent slightly above it but and this
is light tail errors things get really
really crazy when you have heavy tail
there so whereas our procedure is robust
right it doesn't change much it changes
the slope of growing towards getting to
1 but that's kind of expected let me
show you one real data maybe I have one
minute it's a breast cancer data where
we regress the this gene brca1 which is
highly significant for her2 positive
breast cancer and that's the type of
breast cancer we looked at we have more
than 30,000 gene expression values so
this is one of the g ox open source data
set and we wanted to see can we test out
you know can we find the important genes
or not the red is what is biologically
important biologically I don't mean
statistically I mean people have done
experiments knocked out the gene and
found out significant causal
relationships and we are able to find
them what we are also able to
showcase here is that all of this other
things our test which is here does not
find them significant and if you look at
biological Association they are related
to completely different cancers but the
competing methods are saying to us that
they are significant gene expressions so
why is this important because you know
identifying these red ones is really
significant for treatment assignment and
treatment changes and you know
addressing better survival rates for for
breast cancer
now finish with a nice plot if you want
to know what it is it's some finance
prediction stuff I don't have time by
the one aboard you so thank you for your
- what is the plot so it's predicting
it's predicting how do you call it
market sorry okay anyways recession
times okay
so the gray lines sorry I you have this
thing so the gray lines are known are
recession times what we're doing we're
taking macroeconomic variables up to
that time and then building confidence
intervals one step ahead right and doing
that sequentially all the time and if
you see a confidence interval that's
positive the negative values are not
indicative of anything so just a large
positive values mean recession time then
we are able to identify these two and
these two but we're we're missing out on
this one but I think that's important to
know that you can just grab all this
macro variables together and just be
able to actually quantify look at this
it's see these economists they don't
give you data freely for free so yeah on
the y-axis
y-axis risk premium access risk
of the sp500 other questions
[Applause]